hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have requested it's from the
finals of the chess.com world rapid
championship or maybe just rapid
championship it's not the world
championship but still uh some very very
uh incredibly strong players are playing
there and in the finals we have fabiana
quran and hikaru nakamura nakamura
defeating david paramian in the
semi-finals and caruana defeating daniel
dubo uh in the semi-finals also
so it's a brilliant game
and like fabi says uh there is a very
certain bishop g5 line against uh the
berlin defense of the rue lopez uh that
no one knows how to play against uh as
he says he played it uh several times
against wesley so he played it
also in this tournament before facing
hikaru and he always gets a nice game
and since uh the berlin is known to be a
very very drawish um a line of the rue
lopez and uh a lot of strong grand
masters are even using it to force a
very well-known draws it's always
refreshing to see well basically a
miniature against the berlin defense so
now without further ado let's check it
out and see what this is all about uh uh
caruana with the white pieces opens with
e4 we have uh e5 by hikaru knight of
three knight to c6 and the bishop to b5
so the real lopez is on the board knight
to f6 going for the berlin defense and
d3 now all right we have bishop to c5
and now uh c3 is still the most popular
move here but uh corona goes for the
exchange variation bishop captures pawn
captures and now uh there are a lot of
popular moves here knight beat the d2 is
popular castles is popular h3 is popular
queen to e2 is popular uh the move
bishop to g5 not so much and you really
know how you really have to know how to
play against it because it's very very
tricky so the the common replies here
are our bishop to e6 that's a very
popular idea and queen to d6 is a very
popular idea but hikaru plays bishop
back to d6 and it's also one of the ways
of defending the e5 pawn you know that
when you play the berlin there are
several ways you can defend it um
especially if the queens come off the
board then even knight to d7 is an idea
f6 is an idea also bishop back to d6 is
an idea uh but it's not a new game there
exists a game with this exact same over
there knight beat d2 and now comes
bishop to e6 here uh there is a game uh
from 2019 in gerbil to our masters
between niels grandelus and actress
chandra where queen to e7 was played uh
and uh uh niels was able to win this
game with the white pieces however here
he car plays bishop to e6 as that's kind
of a
nice square for the bishop in the berlin
and it is now as of move seven already
that we have a completely new game which
is not very often seen in the berlin
defense so fabi says uh this will simply
not do and he strikes in the center with
the d4 he already played d3 so it's kind
of wasting a tempo
but if it works then it works so black
has to react to this otherwise he loses
the e5 pawn so he plays h6 uh
challenging the bishop now of course if
you capture
on f6 that's not going to be really all
that impressive queen captures the pawn
is defended you've allowed black to
freely develop the queen black and even
castle queen side so everything is on
the board for black now so instead
bishop h4 now comes the bishop to g4
pinning the knight so one of the
attackers of the e5 pawn and here hikaru
castles uh sorry fabi castles after
bishop to g4 and now hikaru plays g5
so uh probably hikaru will not be
castling king's side and he will try to
go for some sort of a king-side attack
this is a rapid game so uh
it makes sense to attack so bishop to g3
and now knight back to d7 uh
adding another defender to the e5 pawn
and maybe having some ideas of advancing
that uh f pawn maybe even the h pawn in
the future so h3 asking uh hikar what do
you do with the bishop on g4 he he
trades at the bishop captures we have
queen captures and now queen the e7 and
now uh here hikaru could be castling
queenside but first knight to c4 by fabi
putting more pressure on that e5 square
so e captures on d4 you could also try
and hold everything with f6 but it's uh
it's a clunky move to throw in hikaru
doesn't like it he plays e characters on
d4 and now knight captures and d6 with c
captures and now rook a to d1
going after the d4 pawn and for the
moment black is up upon but it's uh
really uh well it's a double the depo
nothing really uh happy going on there
for black so knight to the e5 attacking
fabi's queen
and here uh fabi has two choices uh he
could go queen to f5 but also he would
go for the very dangerous queen to a3
queen to a3 uh is such a wonderful move
because it prevents black from really
doing anything the d4 pawn is attacked
you can't castle side because the a7
pawn would fall uh and the castling king
side also isn't um
isn't very impressive castle's king side
the rook captures on d4 and all of your
pawns are already advanced white will
very easily attack this
so it's possible to go queen to a3
however fabi plays queen to f5 and now
what do you do okay the d4 pawn is
attacked so we still uh defend it and
the much like in the queen a3 line if c5
defending the d4 pawn uh fabi would
undermine it with c3 so the the the
century is being challenged and now it's
a difficult position for black because
you can't go queen side you can't go
king side the king is stuck in the
middle of the board with uh
out all that much to do uh if you try
knights to c6 which is kind of the
strongest movie recommended by the
engine then f4 and again black is uh is
not enjoying uh many choices here so it
would be old white to this game but
instead he carl played the d captures on
c3 and now he allows fabi a beautiful
combination to seal the deal uh so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for fabi while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the
weakness of the d6 pawn and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course rook captures on d4 that's
the good stuff
but you have to see this move and the
next one in order to really solve this
because okay now if queen captures then
we're going to play bishop captures we
pick up the rook that's game however of
course hikaru will not allow this car
plays knight to c4 and what do you play
now there's a double attack on the rook
here and also if you just move it back
yes you won the d6 pawn but we're gonna
capture on b2 and then we're gonna have
a beautiful pass pawn on b2 so here is
the movie that you guys had to find in
order to really solve this after rook
captures on d6 and that is queen
captures and c5 and now there really
isn't um
anything black can do everything is
hanging here the position is so open uh
what do you play uh well of course we
have to capture the rook but that will
not help black we have bishop captures
on d6 queen to e6 now and now queen to
b5 with check driving the black king
into the open king to d8 and now before
bringing the rook into the game first
bishop to e5 going after the rook and h8
but also just threatening queen captures
and b7 queen captures rook ander the
rook is still coming to d1 that's not a
question so here rook to e8 by hikaru
and now queen captures on b7
uh we have c2 by hikaru
trying to
throw in or maybe just being a gentleman
as fabio of course says mate in one uh
so
maybe he maybe he missed it maybe he
just wanted to allow fabi to deliver
mate on the board as that is a
gentlemanly thing to do uh whichever the
case was uh fabi plays the queen to c7
and he delivered delivers this beautiful
checkmate so there you have it checkmate
on the board in 25 moves against the
berlin defense this is incredible stuff
and uh
i know you guys hate it when i say that
we are going to show a nice berlin
defense game because you think okay i'm
probably kidding it's going to be a long
tedious game but no
here you have this bishop to g5 line
you've seen it
after the captures on c6 you can play
bishop to g5 and your opponent will not
have an easy time defending this
position as you've seen here in this
game so go online uh wherever you play
play bishop to g5 against the berlin and
you know crush your opponents
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by uh by
fabiano who wins the chess.com rapid
championship uh fabiano being the second
of course uh i would like to thank david
kimura martin uh
alidine diego henriquez matt back with
and gregory bosco for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day